hi I'm kassam basura from Pakistan and
I'm on the Pakistan council here at the
global agenda summit in Abu Dhabi we've
been talking since yesterday about the
different challenges that we want to try
to address it is challenging because we
don't want it to be so broad base that
we are not able to achieve anything at
the end so I think the general sort of
focus that emerging seems to be about
doing something which is going to
encourage inclusive economic growth
trying to bring in both people from the
bottom of the pyramid as well as both
genders so that's one of our main focal
points the other saying that we are
trying to achieve is to talk to people
in the india group and find out if
they'd like to work with us in trying to
promote regional trade in Southeast Asia
and in fact I am supposed to be at a
breakfast right now with the India drew
but I don't over there so thank you